das ist eine außergewöhnliche galaxie
die neue aufgespürte galaxie mit der
bezeichnung r 5 519 ist wirklich in
vielerlei hinsicht sehr besonders sie
ist nicht nur besonders alt und extrem
weit von uns entfernt in ihrer mitte
klafft ein gigantisches loch und damit
lüftet diese entdeckung ein spannendes
geheimnis auch über unsere milchstraße
und noch eine spektakuläre erkenntnis es
gibt zehn mal mehr galaxien als bis vor
kurzem noch vermutet zehnmal mehr
das muss man sich mal vorstellen wir
können sie nur heute noch nicht sehen
aber wann klicks um seine user gibt es
regelmäßig spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktive die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
die galaxie r 5 519 ist wirklich
sonderbar sie ist elf milliarden
lichtjahre von unserem sonnensystem
entfernt und ist dementsprechend genau
so viele jahre alt doch es handelt sich
nicht nur um ein besonders frühe
galaxien exemplar die masse dieser
rätselhafte galaxie entspricht zwar etwa
der masse unserer milchstraße kurios ist
jedoch dass in ihrer mitte ein riesiges
loch klafft sein durchmesser
achtung 2 milliarden astronomische
einheiten also zwei milliarden mal
größer als der abstand zwischen erde und
sonne weil diese seltener galaxie
außerdem kreisförmig ist erinnert sie
mit ihrem loch in ihrer mitte
tatsächlich an einen gigantisch großen
donath da wo sich also in unserer heimat
galaxie ein dichtes zentrum befindet
findet sich hier nichts als gähnende
leere
das zentrale loch ist von einem hellen
ring aus gas und leuchtende sterne
umgeben einem internationalen
forschungsteam gelangen diese spannende
entdeckung jetzt mit hilfe des
weltraumteleskops hubble und desktop sat
1 auf hawaii auch für die fachleute
selbst ist das eine äußerst spektakuläre
entdeckung dazu tian tian yuan der an
der beobachtung beteiligt war es ist ein
sehr merkwürdiges objekt dass wir noch
nie gesehen haben es sieht seltsam und
vertraut zugleich aus den beobachtungen
zufolge produziert diese galaxie 50 mal
mehr sterne als die milchstraße
der größte teil der aktivität ereignet
sich in ihrem ring die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sprechen deswegen von einem feuerring
als ich ihr galaxie außerhalb dieses
rings in einer zone des diffusen
sternenlichts fortsetzt ist sie
insgesamt bis zu zwei mal größer als die
milchstraße die fachleute sind sich
sicher dass sie es hier mit einer
sogenannten kollision sga laxey zu tun
haben und das ist eine echte premiere
denn die donut galaxie m51 9 ist die
erste dieser art die bislang im frühen
universum aufgespürt werden konnte die
große frage wie konnte es zu diesem
sternenring kommen fachleute kennen
bisher zwei wege wie eine solche ring
galaxie entstehen kann
sehr häufig sorgen turbulenzen für
dichte wellen im gas und es kommt zu
einer ungleichmäßigen ringförmigen stern
bildung heißt also dass bei diesem
häufigeren typ innere prozesse die
entstehung auslösen doch eine solche
kollision swing galaxie wie die neu
aufgespürte donath galaxie muss auf
andere art und weise entstanden sein und
zwar durch eine gewaltige kollision fest
steht sie ist nach ansicht der fachwelt
sehr selten selbst in namen universum im
fernen jungen universum wurde solch ein
galaxien typ bislang noch nie aufgespürt
somit liefert uns die entdeckte galaxie
auf 5519 im fernen kosmos super
spannende erkenntnisse zur entstehung
von galaxien wie etwa der milchstraße
und die sind frappierend grundlegend ist
jedenfalls dass galaxien ganz
unterschiedliche formen aufweisen können
die verschiedenen galaxien typen hatte
schon edwin hubble erforscht und seine
klassifikation ist im wesentlichen auch
heute noch so gültig es gibt nicht nur
die ring galaxien mit einem hellen
zentrum und einem hell leuchtenden ring
aus stern der sich davon ganz deutlich
abgrenzt andere galaxien sind kreisrund
oder haben die form einer ellipse die
beiden magellanschen wolken dagegen sind
beispiel für die fuß wolkige stern
ansammlung viele galaxien dagegen bilden
spiralen oder balken spiralen wie
beispielsweise die andromeda galaxie
oder auch unsere milchstraße mehr als
die hälfte aller sternensystemen sind
solche spiralgalaxien die oft auch als
scheiden galaxien bezeichnet werden und
mit dem kürzel s gekennzeichnet werden
bei unserer milchstraße handelt es sich
um eine besondere spiralgalaxien die
deutlich verformt ist denn die äußeren
regionen unserer milchstraße weichen von
der haupt ebene der sternen scheibe auf
der einen seite nach oben und auf der
anderen seite nach unten
bogenförmig ab schaut man sich die
milchstraße in diesem modell also von
der seite an ist sie leicht s förmig
diese sensationelle entdeckung gelang
einem chinesisch australischen
forschungsteam anfang des vergangenen
jahres 2019 dazu der australische
forscher richard dick gries in den
äußeren regionen der galaxie haben wir
zudem festgestellt dass die sve sterben
scheibe in einem zunehmend verbogenen
spiral muster verformt ist doch warum
ist das so
mit der ring galaxie m51 sollen hat das
nichts zu tun
ein italienisches forschungsteam ist
diesem rätsel der milchstraße neben auf
die spur gegangen und hat dabei eine
überraschende entdeckung gemacht demnach
rotiert die wölbung sehr schnell und das
macht klar dass weder dunkle materie im
halo noch das intergalaktische
magnetfeld die ursache für die
verformung sein können denn nach ansicht
der fachleute müsste sich die wölbung
dann sehr viel langsamer bewegen bleibt
also nur noch eine ursache übrig die die
verformung unserer galaxie hervorrufen
kann
höchstwahrscheinlich handelt es sich um
einen zwerg galaxie die sich im nahen
umfeld der image straße befindet und ihr
immer wieder nahe kommt konkret haben
die fachleute
die sanitas zwerggalaxien und ihre
schwerkraft wirkung im verdacht sie ist
etwa 70.000 lichtjahre entfernt und ihre
bahn offenbart dass sie im laufe ihrer
geschichte immer wieder mal in den
außenbereich unserer galaxie
eingedrungen ist vermutlich wird in den
kommenden 100 millionen jahren eine
weitere passage an stehen laut des
italienischen forschungsteams ist das
aber kein grund zur beunruhigung da
weder die werbung selbst noch die
bewegung der sagittarius galaxie einen
spürbaren einfluss auf uns haben dazu
heißt es in der studie
die sonder liegt nur rund 26.000
lichtjahre vom galaxien zentrum entfernt
hier ist die amplitude der wölbung daher
sehr klein erst ab einer entfernung von
etwa 50.000 lichtjahren vom galaktischen
zentrum ist die verformung stärker
ausgeprägt auch wenn es sich für uns
vielleicht so anfühlt die milchstraße
ist keineswegs etwas besonders es
handelt sich einfach um eine mittelgroße
galaxie unter vielen milliarden im
universum eine flache scheibe bei der
die sterne in spiralarmen angeordnet
sind und um das galaxien zentrum kreisen
sie setzt sich also aus unzähligen
sternen planeten und staub und gas
zusammen ihre form behält sie
weil diese materie sich mit ihrer
schwerkraft gegenseitig anzieht im
kosmos verbreitet sind tatsächlich vor
allem flache scheiben galaxien mit einer
kosmologischen simulation hatte ein
internationales forschungsteam im
vergangenen jahr herausgefunden wie
solche scheiben galaxien entstehen und
warum sie so häufig vorkommen dazu hat
das astronomie team sagenhafte 14
milliarden jahre in die vergangenheit
geblickt zu den anfängen des universums
nämlich gar nicht so einfach denn
schließlich müssen für solche
forschungen gigantische datenmengen
verarbeitet werden doch die
rechenleistung ist selbst bei
supercomputern begrenzt die simulation
kann entweder sehr detailgenau sein oder
aber ein großes volumen fassen dabei ist
beides extrem wichtig tng 50 ist mit
recht die bisher detailreichsten
kosmologische groß simulation
doch um diese leistung zu erbringen
haben 16.000 computer kerne kurs auf dem
supercomputer hazel henne in stuttgart
tatsächlich mehr als ein jahr lang rund
um die uhr gerechnet auf einem einzigen
prozessor wäre damit eine rechenzeit von
15.000 jahren notwendig gewesen die
bausteine 20 milliarden teilchen die
nicht nur dunkle materie sterne
kosmisches gas magnetfelder und
supermassereiche schwarze löcher
darstellen und die ganze arbeit hat sich
gelohnt tng 50 zeigt einen
würfelförmigen ausschnittes weltalls mit
seitenlangen von 230 millionen
lichtjahren so werden physikalische
phänomene dargestellt die auf skalen
auftreten die eine million mal kleiner
sind über 13,8 milliarden jahre hinweg
konnte das astronomie team so die
gleichzeitige entwicklung tausender von
galaxien verfolgung so offenbarte die
simulation unter anderem spannende
einblicke dazu wie sich unsere
milchstraße entwickelt hat das große
rätsel über das sich fachleute weltweit
den kopf zerbrechen hängt mit der dünnen
scheiben vom solcher spiralgalaxien
zusammen hier konzentrieren sich gas und
sterne
wann und wie hat sich diese scheiben vom
gebildet und gab es das auch schon bei
früheren galaxien mithilfe der neu
entwickelten groß simulation fanden die
forscher heraus dass diese form der
galaxien hauptsächlich durch die stern
bildung bestimmt wird bei der entstehung
neuer sterne schwenken sich diese auf
kreisbahnen um den kern der galaxie
meinen sie
bringen sie ordnung in das ganze und
zwar durch ihre kreisbewegung dadurch
kommen chaotische gasströme zur ruhe
die sich dann schließlich auch mit dem
galaktischen karussell vereinen dazu die
astronomen anna-lisa philipp ich die an
der studie beleidigt war tmg 50 zeigt
dass sich unsere eigene milchstraßen
galaxie mit ihrer dünnen scheibe voll im
trend befindet in den vergangenen 10
milliarden jahren sind zumindest
diejenigen galaxien in denen noch neue
sterne entstehen immer schwieriger
geworden und ihre chaotischen inneren
bewegungsmuster haben sich deutlich
abgeschwächt das universum war viel
chaotischer als heute als es nur ein
paar milliarden jahre alt war
um es deutlich zu machen durch die
gravitation der sterne dieser neu
entstehenden sterne beziehungsweise
sternensysteme die sich um das zentrum
einer galaxie bewegen und durch die
gegenseitige beeinflussung ziehen sich
diese systeme langsam gegenseitig in
diese scheibe da sie nur so einen
stabilen zustand erreichen können oder
einen stabileren das ist der stabilste
zustand ein system das sich durch
ständige rückkopplung der gravitation in
diesen stabilen zustand beginnt das
system strebt ein gleichgewicht an wie
überall in der physik und das ist am
besten in einer scheibe zu erreichen die
tmg 50 simulation offenbarte außerdem
ein super spannendes phänomen das die
fachleute so nicht erwartet hatten
wenn gaswolken durch supernovae und
ausbrüchen von schwarzen löchern aus
galaxien herausgeschleudert werden
herrscht anfangs chaos doch auch hier
kommt nach und nach ordnung rein die
gasströme ordnen sich zu einer struktur
die zwei eistüten ähnelt beide spitzen
berühren sich die galaxie dabei damit
doch das ganze und das ist frappierend
hatte das forschungsteam vorab nicht
einmal ein programmiert dass bei einer
simulation solch ein ergebnis
herauskommt ist ein großer erfolg dazu
dienen nelson vom max planck institut
für astrophysik in garching diese
phänomene ergeben sich auf natürliche
weise aus dem zusammenspiel der
grundlegenden physikalischen
bestandteile unseres modell universums
numerische experimente dieser art sind
besonders erfolgreich wenn mehr
herauskommt als man hinein gesteckt hat
und die forschenden sind optimistisch
denn die auswertung der tmg 50
simulation hat gerade erst begonnen und
klar ist das universum hält sicherlich
noch viele überraschungen für uns bereit
erst vor vier jahren hatten forscher
herausgefunden dass sie die zahl der
galaxien im all gewaltig unterschätzt
hat demnach sind es zehn mal so viele
galaxien wie eigentlich vermuten zehnmal
mathematische modelle legen nämlich
demnach nahe dass rund 90 prozent der
galaxien für uns mit der heutigen
generation von teleskopen gar nicht
erkennbar sind im beobachtbaren kosmos
liegt die gesamtzahl der galaxien dieser
studie zufolge bei mehr als einer
billion dazu der britische astronomen
christopher conze lies es sprengt das
vorstellungsvermögen dass mehr als 90
prozent der galaxien im universum noch
untersucht werden müssen wer weiß was
wir für interessante eigenschaften
entdecken werden wenn wir diese galaxien
mit der nächsten generation von
teleskopen beobachten eines davon wird
ja das james webb weltraumteleskop seien
eigentlich sollte es im märz 2021
staaten doch wegen corona konnte an dem
teleskop nicht weiter gearbeitet werden
wann der staat jetzt stattfindet ist
ungewiss bis wären mit diesem mega
teleskop also in die tiefen des alls
blicken können kann nur vermutet werden
wie die verborgenen galaxien aus sehen
die fachleute gehen davon aus dass es im
jungen universum sehr viel mehr und vor
allem kleinere galaxien gab die im laufe
der zeit für den großen galaxien wie der
milchstraße verschmolzen sind aber wie
konnte die nun neu aufgespürte und sehr
seltene ring galaxie entstehen die an
einem donut erinnert und was sagt sie
über unsere milchstraße
fest steht es handelt sich um die erste
jemals aufgespürte ring galaxie im
fernen kosmos die durch eine kollision
entstanden ist dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam in der aktuellen studie
das ausgedehnte diffuse sternenlicht um
den stern bildungs ring kombiniert mit
dessen radialgeschwindigkeit und einem
koalitionspartner nahebei liefern belege
dafür dass diese galaxie einen kollision
string besitzt die fachleute gehen davon
aus dass sich solche kollision string
galaxien nur dann bilden können wenn die
ausgangs galaxie schon eine innere dünne
sternen scheibe ausgebildet
hat hier befinden sich vor allem jüngere
sterne dazu der wissenschaftler kennen
stream an der an der studie beteiligt
war
die entstehung von galaxien durch eine
kollision setzt voraus dass vorher eine
dünne scheibe in der opfer galaxie
vorhanden ist die dünne scheibe ist der
bestimmende bestandteil von
spiralgalaxien bevor sie sich zusammen
führte waren die galaxien in einem
ungeordneten zustand und noch nicht als
spiralgalaxien erkennbar
bei dieser ring galaxie schauen wir also
elf milliarden in das frühe universum
zurück eine zeit also in der sich dünne
scheiben gerade erst kommt das heißt
also weil die galaxie er 5519 schon sehr
alt ist hat sie wahrscheinlich schon vor
elf milliarden jahren eine solche dünne
scheibe ausgebildet bei der kollision
bildete sie sich daraus dann der
sternenring zum vergleich dazu die dünne
scheibe der milchstraße begann sich wohl
erst vor etwa neun milliarden jahren zu
bilden die fachleute schließen daraus
dass die scheiben anordnung in
spiralgalaxien also über einen deutlich
längeren zeitraum erfolgen als man
bislang angenommen hatte sprich dass
galaxien so aussehen wie unsere
milchstraße ist eng mit ihrem alter
verbunden im frühen universum sahen noch
mehr galaxien deutlich anders aus das
universum hat also sein aussehen im
laufe der zeit verändert die
schlussfolgerung also auch in zukunft
könnte sich das aussehen verändern was
wir zum beispiel jetzt schon wissen das
universum treibt immer weiter
auseinander irgendwann ist alles so weit
voneinander entfernt dass wir keine
anderen galaxien mehr sehen können zehn
sehr große galaxien im universum
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar regis kosmos spektakulärer kanal
die nicht nur empfehlen kann bis dann
bleibt dran